foreign
but a few months later he was sent back
the whole experience
made me pay attention to the criminal
justice system for the first time
I started talking to researchers
Advocates and eventually to the people
who run the U.S prison system
what surprised me most in those
conversations was something they all
agreed on
everyone the left the right Advocates
agencies agreed that change was being
slowed down by bad data
data that was scattered stale incomplete
data that made it really hard to know it
was working
data's so bad that people who had done
everything that they needed to do to be
released from prison were still stuck in
the system
altogether bad data means that hundreds
of thousands of people
are in prison and on probation and
parole who don't need to be there
people like Kate
in 2018 Kate was sentenced to four years
on probation for a drug charge
at sentencing the judge told her that if
she was doing well she could cut that
sentence in half
today she's sober employed has stable
housing she's got kids who are doing
great
she did everything the judge asked but
she's still on probation
Kate's parole officer Allison has been
an officer in Idaho for six years and
she's great at her job
but her job is kind of impossible she is
responsible for 90 people
who each need to do 21 things in order
to be released
and those 21 things live in five
different databases so earned credits in
one place drug tests in another fines
and fees in another
phone reception is bad in most parole
offices so to get the code to log into
each system she'd have to go to the
parking lot
and she would have to do that for 90
people every day manually just to know
who had already done everything they
needed to do to be released
so you can see how people fall through
the cracks
and it's hundreds of thousands of people
nobody likes this I've spent the last
three years working with the people who
run state prison systems and I can tell
you that nobody likes the fact that
people are stuck in the system because
databases aren't talking to each other
it got like this because we have a
fragmented system that grew really fast
starting in the 70s we saw runaway
growth at every level of the U.S justice
system
state prisons County jails City police
departments
all running their own collection of
databases that don't talk to each other
fast forward to today and both sides of
the aisle have fought to undo that
growth passing Common Sense laws that
let people who are succeeding earn their
way out
but the data that an officer like
Allison would need to actually enact
those laws is still scattered across all
those different systems
Criminal Justice Reform is complex
but this specific part of the problem
has a very clear solution
we can bring the data together
we can build tools for decision makers
and those tools can directly translate
to more people getting out of the system
and staying out of the system
that's what we do at recidivists we're a
non-profit engineering team
and for officers like Allison we built a
tool that answers three questions
who is eligible for release literally
right now
who's almost eligible but just needs to
do one more thing like send in a picture
of their pay stub
and who actually needs help getting
treatment getting a job finding housing
it's the simplest tool that you can
imagine but it means that suddenly
Allison can help the people who actually
need it
and help everyone else get back to their
lives
we launched this tool in Idaho six
months ago
within weeks Kate was released
within months five percent
of people on probation and parole had
either been moved to lower levels of
supervision or moved out of the Criminal
Justice System entirely
all right
five percent five percent
let's say we scale just that to all 50
states
that alone would impact 200 000 people
like Kate
and it's just the first step that's one
piece of the puzzle we need better data
at every level of Criminal Justice
decision making
so that Corrections leaders can see
which treatment programs work
so that supervisors can find and fix
these broken processes that pull people
back in
so that policy makers can see which laws
are holding people back
these are the leaders that Americans are
looking to to reduce incarceration to
reduce racial disparities to save
taxpayer dollars and to do it all safely
we're asking them to make pretty bold
changes while Flying Blind
data can't fix the U.S justice system
but it can help 200 000 people who are
stuck
it can show us which strategies are
working it can give us the confidence
that the laws that we fight for are
actually helping the people that they're
designed to help
we started this work because it felt
like a clear place for software
Engineers to pitch in
but it turns out that getting data to
decision makers
is one of the most promising strategies
we have for transforming the whole
system
so today
three years eight states and thousands
of people later
feels like we're just getting started
thank you
[Applause]